[crabs dancing song]
*Jammin' Pewds*
Everybody!
Welcome to meme review, the place where we have fun memes, review trivia, and learn more info and fun facts about memes.
[more crab music]
brah
AHHHHHHHHHOMAIGODHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!1
Somebody kill me!
Please, it's muffin time!
I especially like this meme because it's, it's issa fun celebratory theme
I can really not think of any other better track that to be played during my funeral and where is Obama?
Where has he gone and why is pewdiepie reviewing this meme now?
[visible silence]
When it's three months old?
[Crab earrape] *out-of-breath jammin' pewds*
*swedish accent* Pause the video!
PAUSE the video!!!!
*pewds* I didn't read the text..... oh my goodddd
[It was 'my whole family is dead']
It's nothing f(e)unny about that.
[MORE MUSIC]
I think I finally learned to do the Fortnite dance. (That's the floss, pewds)
If I do it really slowly I can do it.
But you can't even see. You can't even see it, what the frick?
This...
This song is the perfect... It's a perfect mashup of happiness and sadness
There's really no other way to put it it's the Alpha and the Omega
[music]
Anytime anything bad happens in your life, you know what to do...
It's time to hit it to this song
[visible silence]
Any loved ones died?
Why cry about it?
When you can just have an epic crab party about it!
Why I emit any actual real emotions?
When you can just...
Hide them through memes.
Why have any coherent thought in general?
There's always just a meme a click away.
[family friendly content]
How old is Shera L. Greenwood?
OH MY GOD!!!!!!!!!
HAAAH
*Aggressive pewds fist pump with mildly sexual sounds*
[ visible silence ] (RIP HEADPHONES)
Okay, THAT'S EPIC!
Scientists have broken down.
What makes this song so special? Why this song out of all songs in the whole entirety of you the universe?
What makes it so special?
felix dying from the inside
Why does anyone watch the- my videos?
The crab meme *Pewds meme review clap*  ...gets of course, a solid it's a solid seven point....
Four...?
Pretty good.
Sorry, though, it's over. Bye-bye crab. Bye-bye!
No more crab meme dancing for you.
Consider this meme just as dead as my emotions.
Thank you very much for your service crab meme, it's been a pleasure.
*Sp00ky music and gunshots*
Come on, Come on!
I want you to do it... I want you to say the n-word... COMEON
Come on... COME ON!!!!!!
Say the n-word... SAY THE N-WORD
Come on I want you to say the n-word
AHHHHHHHH
SAY THE N-WORD
*screeching tires and crash*
This is a very important announcement we talked about this last week
But the EU have made a new little rule
So don't say it. Don't say- think it don't say it don't
Think it don't s-ay it the n-word. Okay. I told me I freaking told you guys last time and look at this
What the Frick goggle is racist goggle niger
Why I didn't know Google was raised how can the biggest company say the n-word what the f-
That's almost as bad as the biggest youtuber. Oh, you're not convinced yet
Not convinced yet
You're still thinking about it
It can you can you can't look look look what happened to my fellow friend YouTuber The Annoying Orange
I'm going to say the n-word
ThAT's racISt you can't say the n-wORd
*intense apple inhale*
Ni-AHHEEEEAIEEEAAEAIIAAEEEEEEAAAA
Don't say it don't think it okay remember and be kind to each other and
Now a word from our sponsor
*Singing in little foreign voice*
That's right everybody and please rest assured
just because we have a sponsor that doesn't- that's not gonna change meme review
Okay, it's not the money and fame is not gonna go to our heads here
over at meme review. Everything will stay the same
Don't worry guys. We'll always bring that
Dankest memes. Okay, even though we have ninja sponsoring this video
thank you guys so much check out ninja in the description enter the code ninja
and, uh...
Next meme
David- bro- David
I Mean, I know you're a sophisticated guy
The world is a mess. The world is as angry as it gets
Well, you think this is gonna cause a little more anger
The world is an angry place this just in on a special meme review pew new segment
Donald Trump is a gamer.
*Pewds clapping*
I think this is really gonna turn some heads and really change some minds
What do you guys think as always passing the question on to you guys?
Okay, okay. Alright this- this one
*reading*
Me,,, Cool stick my dog found,,, my dog
haHA
John wick in need of a gold scar,,, my mom's credit card info,,, me
2018 memes just summarize[d]  just put a text on it
*reading*
Cannibalism would solve both overpopulation and world hunger,,, me,,, a normal conversati-
Stop adding text to every goddamn image you find on the Internet, Okay?
fifth-grader turning off youtube autoplay teachhhhr-
Some demon dude,, sword,,, knight-
*Pewds taken aback by the meta meme*
What the Frick
What I don't get that one
*reading*
MorkarDFC,,, Fame and recognition,,, this meme
what the Frick is this you don't recognize the artist on meme review. What is this?
Don't worry guys. We're not running low on memes at all. Okay, I got ton of great stuff
I got so much great stuff coming up the- on meme review, so how about this one
*reading*
wooden stock,,, synthetic stock,,, laughing stock
Flat Earth community- *pewds laugh*
Those people are dumb, right?
Idiots, okay. Okay. Okay. All right. Sorry. Sorry *unintelligible pewds gibberish*
Alright how about this one
being red
Piss
cum
wait a minute. Wait a minute. Wait the Frick who made this meme
guys can we please this is super important
Whoever made this meme
Can we try and contact whoever made this meme
'cause I'm pretty sure that piss and cum is not supposed to be red
So I think he could actually or she could be in big-
*Pewds news???*
Poppy Harlow here with another special news segment
a new Smasha Bro-as
Super Smash brother character have been announced
that's right hackers have figured out
go to smash bros dot com (SmashBros.com) if you don't think this is real
click on their Korean thing hit translate
Click on fighter scroll down and there you have-
ejaculation salt the new character. Can't wait to play as him
I think- I wonder what his moves are- *Pewds gibberish*
I'm so glad they haven't announced Louie
waluigi yet
Because ejaculation salt is really who i've been waiting for
He's really the character that I think you know, I was on the fence before if I should actually buy this game or not
But now I'm super onboard with that- with that
With the- what is this?
RPG
Clipity clap
This is super important serious guys, can we get some serious music going?
Ok, I have a freaking question to you guys when you this is personal is for real
I want you to answer honestly in the comments preferably so I get more comments
no for other- okay for science
when you walk
Up the stairs or down the stairs
Be 100% on this (You mean 100% truthful pewds)
Do you walk one step or two steps?
Because a new science data has shown that people who walk down two stairs at a time
Are wAy
stronger way more powerful way smarter
it's basic- you might- if you walk one stair- step at a time you might as well just consume- put soy-
soy right up your- you might as well put soy right into your bloodstream because you're not gonna get any
masculinity or epic muscles like me
Okay, if you don't walk two steps at a time
I got little to zero respect for you as a human being
Or I wouldn't even call you that I would call the a lazy Slava blob
that's what you are a blob,a go, A JElly bowl a bowl of jelly, which have no comprehension
of society you disgust me walk down two steps at a time goddammit and then and then I can look in the
Freaking eyes now. Why am I saying this all the sudden? Yeah, because a new
Science study came out of this. Do you think I'm just
giving out gibberish and
pseudoscience
Just for the sake of memes and just for the sake of my political argument
I laughed I laughed I'll admit I laughed
how about this thing, Huh? a science b- in October 6
2006 you get up the stairs faster
Honestly try to refute this lib tards people who walk on stairs two steps at a time
What do you do with a free time you like developing muscle strength, huh?
Look at your legs you might as well have toothpicks as legs. There is one problem though. There is one flaw with this
I will admit when there's an odd number of stairs
You can change your life today, too. All you gotta do is walk two steps at a time. It's not that hard.
Okay
that was
That was meme review for this week
*Pewds slow clap*
That's it for this weeks
meme review everybody. Hope you enjoyed the Memes.
Hope you had fun. Hope you learn something new today
Smash like for meme review and thumbs down for- for  T-Series
bye
Is it the Banana????
Oh shit!!!
Oh No
Sadness Everywhere....